I love your character in this film it's  you really portray this character  beautifully and he's a guy whose dreams  haven't quite come true there's a lot of  complexities to the character and and  also I liked your look in the movie  who's a different look for you had a  mustache you're kind of a guy that  doesn't I think we have a still eeeh  there you grow what's that for yeah  did you like having a mustache it was  fun because I lived in New York in a  hotel and I was would lay in bed and I'd  say must I'd say to my wife mustache  rise for a dollar I thought I was gonna  end up with a fun evening but then my  kids ran in with two dollars I like can  we go and no no no no what is it what is  that I say one thing right I said no no  no I said mustard eyes and I squirted  him in the eyes yeah I'm good and all  your stories your children are confused  to met them they're very inaudible  they're all know your story son  I'm pretending they're the young me  you